without naming names can you tell us a
story about how
a studio took was it your script or one
of your ideas
which time um i i'm really a big
proponent on protecting your work
i will go on record to say don't waste
your 20 or dollars doing wga west
it's a waste of time it doesn't do any
good um it's not gonna
do what you want it to do spend the
extra 25 dollars and do it with the usco
the u.s
library of congress
u.s copyright office is what that stands
for the process is just as easy
the copyrights last forever not five
years copyrights
uh cover your legal expenses
to defend the fact that you got ripped
off
and as we're young and naive coming up
in hollywood we tend to
really love to share our work with
people and i always tell people
don't you dare send a script to anybody
until it's finished and copy written
because it's too easy the person you're
sending it you could steal it the person
that you sent it to could send it to a
friend who needs an idea
or hey i'm thinking about getting into
screenwriting do you have any scripts
laying around i can look at and kind of
use as a model well the easiest thing to
do for a new writer is to look at
somebody else's work and just
copy it what happens i've been ripped
off over the years i actually had
a script get
produced by a studio who i'll
not name they actually went out made the
movie it was a 9 million dollar indie
low budget film that they they put the
money behind to make
and they were dumb enough not to even
change the title of the film
or the character names so i guess
whoever brought it to them
took my work and just put their name on
a cover sheet and just did it as is
i gotten wind of this when they were in
post
and what you're supposed to do when you
get ripped off is you let the film come
out
like let it get on the books and let the
trailers start hitting and then that
that monday before the friday is when
you drop your bomb
because they are so vested in this with
the 20 million in pna
or whatever it is they're going to work
out a deal with you
and instead stupid here new somebody who
knew somebody who worked at the studio
when i heard it was in post-production i
made noise about it and then the film
just disappeared it never came out it
was never finished
but they indeed um my friend got me a
copy of the script there was a polish on
the script but they kept the names the
same to kept the title the same i go on
imdb
it's still there unreleased 15 years
later
but it's just kind of funny this movie
got made that never
never even got finished no release
so that was one i've had agencies
take projects and give them to
showrunners days after
we meet on them sometimes
hours after i've had a project that was
packaged by a major agency
in an 07 when the crash hit my investors
backed out
we were three weeks away from rolling
film and you know when the
the 07 recession hit my investors had to
back out so the project never got made
and then
weirdly enough two years later the
packaging agent
got a new client who shot pretty much
the same script
wound up making it in the sundance and
doing quite well
and at least they changed the title they
changed the character names
and the best part was they changed the
opening scene but the rest of the movie
was pretty much
in step so you know i don't make noise
about that stuff anymore
i've learned and that's probably why i
become an independent filmmaker
if i have an idea i'm passionate about
i'm not sending it to you i'm just going
to go make it
that's what i've gotten is i just don't
share my work with anybody
if something i believe in and want to do
it stays in house and
we'll do it so that's usually how a lot
of people do it if they feel their ideas
been stolen
they wait till the week of well you'll
often hear about a film that comes out
and you'll hear
writers are making noise they said their
idea was taken and that's usually when
the film is coming out and what happens
is you get the studio or the network so
vested in the project they've completely
paid the entire process
now they're going through the marketing
and pa and they've committed a good year
a year and a half to the project
and then all of a sudden it's coming out
and you know it's not common but
it's not rare where you hear this
movie's coming out and there's a couple
of writers who say that they were
ripped off and more often than not those
stories disappear and go away
and i think if you're able to prove it
i always say you know you have to take
copious notes i always say
i have a backup email address so anytime
you send a script to somebody send it to
another address you have
and keep those things print them out
save them on a cloud
so you have a track record if you send a
script to somebody you have a
conversation with somebody keep a
journal hey
i spoke to this agent at this agency on
this day about this actor and this
project
because you know it's just if you're
gonna ever make noise that you
were ripped off you have to have you
have to have
chapter and verse copious notes on
everything that that you've done or
there's just no
you know ideas don't cut in anymore you
have to show that there was an
interaction
well it's kind of like the guys that
pointed the finger at zuckenberg for
ripping off facebook i mean they still
probably got two three four hundred
million dollars
it was an undisclosed settlement but
they were able to prove this guy
took their platform and did something
else with it and that you have to think
of it the same way you have to have the
blueprints
for your work you have to have detailed
journal you have to have your
communications
and when they were what they were and
who they were with
so yeah and copyrighted with the library
of congress
so is that is that true that it's easier
for hollywood to just deal with the
lawsuit than pay
i think everybody likes dealing with a
lawsuit than going through the
the painstaking uh it seems everybody
today wants the easy way out
it's easy to rip off things it's too
easy to take advantage i know a very
prominent producer who since passed away
so i'm going to tell the story without
mentioning a name
you know he found a script he was he was
a very successful producer
and he had been nominated for an oscar 3
and found a script
from an unknown writer who wasn't in a
wga or anything
and basically worked out a deal to pay
the guy
peanuts and wound up becoming a very
successful trilogy
and you know just bought and sold the
script over and over until he got it
where it needed to go and
you know it's it just seems like
hollywood's kind of
copying itself anyway i mean that's what
it does right every story's been told
it's how we tell it
you know shark movies are big right now
let's make a shark movie football movies
are big right now let's do a football
movie i mean you know
like we capitalized on that with great
iron gang you know we had we are
marshall you had invincible yet we are
giants we're facing the giants
yeah friday night lights it started it
so you had this movement of football
movies
and it's no different i mean that's just
what they do incidentally what's
interesting is the same guy who
took that script for peanuts it turned
out
admitted to me later he was trying to
make great iron gang with another studio
and he never had the rights to do it
so it goes to show you you know it's
people will just
easily take an idea and run with it and
yeah he never had the rights to do it
[Laughter]
you know how do you feel when somebody
rips off your work it's i guess the old
saying is imitation is the greatest form
of flattery but
when you're reading the front page of
the trades and a big star is attached to
a project that you walked into an agency
or a network
you know my dad always talks about how
he had brought in a uh
a script back in the in the early 70s
called special weapons assault tactics
and was told that's not for us and then
you know
years later
[Music]
so i uh i learned you know
be careful with your product but how
does it feel when you're ripped off it
it
it hurts because you have that it's
almost you know it's like if you've ever
walked into your house
after it's been robbed it's the ultimate
it's the ultimate betrayal it's the
ultimate form of
of uh you know
it's a violation i don't know why
somebody can't just say hey
kid you wrote a script it's pretty good
the idea is there
we want to take it and work we're going
to pay you i mean just the deception
that happens with these things and i i
can't emphasize enough that you have to
i mean it feels empty you look at that
time and you
most writers especially write things on
spec
because one day wouldn't it be great and
then one day you have a library of
scripts that you can look back and say
you have these 10 scripts but
each script takes time whether you're a
fast writer or slow writer i know people
that spend three months on a screen play
i know people spend 10 years on a
screenplay i know somebody's actually
under 30th year on the same script
i cannot imagine if that got
ripped off i mean 30 years think about
it so
i tend to take things well that i tend
to take bad news well
so i didn't get all wrapped up in it i
just okay lesson learned chalk it up is
a life lesson and move on
did you get any compensation for it
shane i never got compensated
there are three projects that i did that
i created that got
taken um one was produced into a film
that never came out
the other one went into pretty hardcore
development at a major network with a
big star attached it never
never did come
there was another one that it was
basically
we had a pretty good timeline and proof
that there was there was a rip-off
um and what was interesting is the the
the institution the studio whatever you
want to call it that did the ripping off
had also
optioned another project from us
previously so what they basically did is
they took
intellectual property that they had
optioned from us
and put it into another project a
storyline into another project that they
already greenlit
totally separate they were going to make
that anyway they were hoping to make
ours
ours didn't really come to fruition so
they kind of grabbed some stuff and
threw it in there
we hired the best of the best lawyers
and
they were unbelievable in how they
structured this case and their timelines
and
at the end of the day nobody wants to go
to court nobody wants to sue anybody i'm
a firm believer in the blacklist i know
people and i don't mean the script side
i'm talking about people saying we're
not going to work with him because
and it just got to a point where you
know other deals other options were made
hey you know
so do you get paid for it no sometimes
if it's handled in a certain way and i
think right you could
possibly uh you could you could
entertain another deal or two with
with a with an an institution that
would admit maybe they wronged you or
were upset you felt wronged
you know optioning another piece of
property for
two or three years isn't uncommon i
guess
if you play your cards right basically
what happened is they just said look you
know
all right we did what we did and you
guys want to go through a lot we're
going to bankrupt you in lawsuits it's
going to take 12 years to engage
do you have something else we can option
and you know they're not going to make
it but
you know but that's how they do it i
mean that's how that's how it worked on
the third
on the first on the studio one yeah yeah
they you know they'll come up with
creative ways to make you feel or hey
why don't we give you a development deal
and that would have to pay anything they
just take a few gratuitous meetings with
you over the course of two years and you
feel like you got yours you know
interesting it's it's weird you know
it's it's a deceptive business and i
think that's what's driven me i'm
i don't i don't ever want to thumb my
nose at hollywood proper i've had a lot
of
success in it and thank god for it and
hope to work again in it i don't
count on it and i don't care if i don't
i went
real rogue independent in what i do
because i just got tired of dealing with
a machine
i got tired of developing you know fall
in love with an idea
put it together whether you've got eight
dollars or eight hundred thousand
dollars and go do it what's stopping you
you know i mean the next film i'm doing
we're starting
in in a couple months and it it
started because a group of us were sick
and tired of sitting around during covet
and we figured we can toss 20 20 in the
garbage
bin like a lot of people are or we can
show something we have something to show
for it
and it was kind of like we know two guys
with two great cameras and a sound guy
we got actors that want to play i got a
great writer who's
got a ton of material i'll direct
produce and cut the thing for free i
don't care let's make this year
something
and then it turned into something where
investors have gotten involved in
better actors and bigger actors and crew
and
now all of a sudden we have a real movie
we're gonna go make and it happened
because we just got sick and tired of
sitting around
and started putting things into motion
we never asked anybody for money
that was the last thing we just wanted
to get busy and have something to show
for 2020.
and the next thing you know we're in
full-blown pre-production on a show
you know so i think i like that
there's no development there's let's do
it
you